♪ ♪
>> TOP DEMOCRATS CALLING OUT THE
MEDIA AND THEIR OWN PARTY.
YES, YOU HEARD ME CORRECTLY.
FIRST, NANCY PELOSI URGING THE
PRESS TO STOP THE
AROUND-THE-CLOCK COVERAGE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> I WISH THE PRESS WOULD SPEND
A LOT MORE TIME ON WHAT WE NEED
TO DO HERE TO MEET THE MEDES OF
THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF MORNING, NOON,
AND NIGHT, ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK YOU'D HAVE MORE VIEWERS
OR READERS ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE RATHER THAN JUST
THIS ONGOING, ONGOING COVERAGE
OF WHAT'S CURRENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT FROM ONE DAY TO THE
NEXT.
>> OUTGOING MISSOURI
SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL
TELLING DEMOCRATS TO STOP
FOCUSING SO MUCH ON GENDER
POLITICS.
>> I THINK ONE OF THE MISTAKES
WE MAKE AS A PARTY IS SPENDING
TOO MUCH TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
GENDER THING.
WE ARE A PARTY OF ALL KINDS OF
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, WHITE MEN, WHITE
WORKING-CLASS MEN HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN A HUGE PART
OF OUR PARTY.
WE HAVE LOST A PART OF THEM.
ONE OF THE REASONS IS WE'VE HAD
A TENDENCY TO TALK, MAYBE, TOO
MUCH ABOUT GENDER.
>> I WOULD AGREE.
I WOULD SAY IDENTITY POLITICS IS
A DIVISIVE THING.
REPUBLICANS AREN'T ANNOUNCING,
HEY, WE ARE THE PARTY OF MEN!
JOIN US!
DEMS HAVE NOTED VOICES LIKE
GILLIBRAND SAYING WE ARE THE
PARTY OF WOMEN, AND I THINK
WOMEN PUT OFF BY THE EXACT
THING.
I THINK IT'S PATRONIZING QUICKLY
PATRONIZING.
>> WHO CARES?
>> YOU KNOW YOU ARE HAVING A
WRONG PATH WHERE PELOSI SAYS
DON'T GO THERE.
SHE IS TRYING TO GIVE THE MEDIA
AND AN IDIOT INTERVENTION
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN IDIOTIZED
BY THEIR DISTASTE OF TRUMP.
I LOVE HER COAT.
DO YOU THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF
WHAT JESSE BROUGHT UP, THAT SHE
KNOWS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN D.C.
WHO ARE GUILTY OF THE SAME THING
AND PAYOUTS FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PAID FOR BY US, THE
TAXPAYER, BUT DO YOU THINK THAT
SHE KNOWS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
GO DOWN A REALLY BAD PATH?
>> MY THING -- I THINK SHE'S
BEEN SAYING THESE TYPE OF
THINGS, BUT BECAUSE SHE WASN'T A
LEADER, SHE HAD NO POWER, NO ONE
LISTENED TO HER, NOW PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY LISTENING TO HER.
>> I THINK SHE WANTS TO START
OFF ON HEALTH CARE AND THE MEDIA
WANTS TO START OFF ON SCANDALS
AND IMPEACHMENT.
SHE'S LIKE A TERRIBLE TV
EXECUTIVE.
SHE IS, LIKE MY GUYS IN THE
MEDIA, DON'T COVER THE TRUMP
SCANDAL, COVER HEALTH CARE
POLICY!
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
OF COURSE THEY ARE GOING TO DO
THAT.
THEY WON ON HEALTH CARE.
IT'S THAT MITCH McCONNELL
THING.
MITCH IS, OKAY, WE ARE
CONFIRMING JUDGES, TAX CUTS,
DOING THIS ON TRADE.
YOU GUYS ARE JUST COVERING THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
CAN I GET A LITTLE CREDIT HERE.
WITH CLAIRE McCASKILL, IT'S
FUNNY.
BEING A RED STATE DEMOCRATS,
IT'S KIND OF LIKE WRITING MAKE A
BULL.
ONLY GOING TO BE ON THE FLOOR,
LIKE, ONE TERM, MAY BE TO GO
TERMS.
THE ONLY REASON YOU GOT THERE IS
BECAUSE SOMEONE DIED, THERE IS A
MAJOR SCANDAL, OR, LIKE, THEY
NOMINATED -- SOME GUY WHO LIKES
TO DATE TEENAGED GIRLS BUT
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON YOU ARE
THERE.
HOLD ON TIGHT.
WHEN THEY ARE GONE, THEY GO,
HATE, DEMOCRATS, THERE'S A WHOLE
COUNTRY OUT THERE.
TRUST ME, YOU CAN PLAY THE
GENDER CARD ALL THE TIME.
>> WHY AREN'T YOU ON THE
"SPECIAL REPORT"?
>> THAT'S WHAT I ASKED BRETT THE
OTHER DAY!
>> I THINK THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING COMMENT BY PELOSI
AND I THINK YOU GUYS ARE RIGHT.
I THINK SHE WANTS PEOPLE TO
COVER REAL ISSUE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT SHE WANTS DEMOCRATS TO BE
ON IN THE HEAD OF THE 2020 RACE
AND PEOPLE WON'T BE ABLE TO SAY
IT'S JUST ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS'
SCANDAL, INVESTIGATE TRUMP.
ONE THING THAT STRIKES ME, I
WANT TO SAY QUICKLY, THE END OF
THE WEEKLY STANDARD.
YOU HAVE A CONSERVATIVE MAGAZINE
THAT COULD BE CRITICAL OF TRUMP
AND THEY GET PUSHED OUT.
SAME THING HAPPENED TO THE
NATIONAL REVIEW WHEN THEY WERE
CRITICAL.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHY.
>> I DO.
>> I KNOW WHY.
>> HERE'S MY POINT.
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA BUBBLE, IF YOU ARE PRO
TRUMP, THAT'S ALL PEOPLE WANT TO
HEAR.
THEY WANT TO AFFIRM, TRUMP IS
OKAY.
EVERY BODY IS COMING BY ATTACKS
BY THE LIBERAL PRESS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON?
>> MY POINT SPECIFICALLY WAS
ABOUT "THE WEEKLY TO
STANDARD."
>> THEY WERE LOSING SUBSCRIBERS.
>> THAT'S NOT IT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WERE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT.
EMILY, WITH CLAIRE McCASKILL
SAYING YOU CAN'T JUST TALK TO
WOMEN IN THE PARTY, TO THE
REPUBLICANS, DO THEY ALSO NEED
TO TALK ABOUT WOMEN?
THEY LOST WOMEN IN THE 2018
MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND THEN GOT
GROUND TO MAKE UP.
>> YES, THERE WAS AN AGGRESSIVE
MESSAGING BY THE LEFT IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS TOWARDS WOMEN,
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE MORE
SIGNIFICANCE TO BE ACHIEVED TO
IF ALL MAKE IF IT WASN'T TERM
SPECIFIC THERE THAT'S WHEN YOU A
SPECIFIC THERE THAT'S WHEN YOU I
SPECIFIC THERE THAT'S WHEN YOU N
SPECIFIC THERE THAT'S WHEN YOU T
SPECIFIC THERE THAT'S WHEN YOU E
EVERYONE WHO'S NOT A WOMAN.
I WENT TO A DIVERSITY EVENT
RECENTLY, BUT IT WAS NEVER
CALLED THAT.
THE PLANNERS AT THE WHOLE
COMMITMENT WAS FOR DIVERSITY AND
THERE'S A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE AND
WHATEVER, BUT IT WAS A CERTAIN
FINANCE EVENT.
>> WHAT WAS IT CALLED?
BECAUSE "THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW."
THE POINT WAS EVERYONE RELAXED
RATHER THAN BE CONFINED TO THIS
TYPE OF, OH, I'M SOME STOMACH
THIS.
I DISAGREE WITH YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE CONSERVATIVE BUBBLE THAT IS
IN A KNEE-JERK PRO TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ON THE BUBBLE.
>> WHO WOULD THAT BE?
>> DO YOU WANT ME TO NAME NAMES?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
ON THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING ABOUT
THE WOMAN THING.
I THINK IT'S A 23-POINT GENDER
GAP IN THE MIDTERMS.
YOU LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENED, I
THINK THERE ARE, LIKE, 30
SOMETHING FRESHMAN DEMOCRATIC